up
up again the dominant side of this form
so here I'm able to drive him in but he
locks his elbow down so I can't really
get in here very well with the EO I
continue through with my body and I hit
my body into his extended elbow this
going to make him Lean Forward just a
little bit as that happens I wrap
underneath his arm and here as he's
lower than me I push into the Shoulder
Through the arm so I drive the arm down
here making him come down at this point
we have three options we show them one
at a time so that way we kind of get a
feel for them one is I can go into the
shoulder by pushing down up and over two
I can tighten here on his elbow and move
into the elbow three I can fold the
wrist down like a go and go into
those one more time it
speak